another stat that a lot of people don't  know is that it's a very small  percentage of men that have access to  all of the women so when women talk  about 80 percent of women if you ask  them what they want in a man what they  would need to like marry a dude or be  with a dude they'd list 20 of men and  that's on the high end sometimes it's  five percent sometimes it's ten percent  sometimes it's 15 so the men that you're  talking about that want three wives um  the majority of men would be happy with  any wife  they would just be happy with anyone  because the majority one in three men  under 30 aren't haven't slept with  anyone in the past year or are virgins